miracle-workers which is it's coming
here soon soon at some point I don't
know yeah steal it on the internet don't
do that it's you and Steve Buscemi yeah
it is myself and Steve Buscemi's super
Steve Buscemi plays God that's the
that's the very short pitch of the
series that's how I'm just you know if
that doesn't get you interested they'll
go away but yeah he's playing God kind
of presiding over a heaven that is
falling apart and chaotic and we have to
any kind of like on a whim decides to
end the world and then me and a bunch of
other characters who are kind of very
low-level angels have to convince him
that the earth is worth saving and it's
very just like sweet and earnest but
also very dark and a lot of people die
we've got a picture of you this isn't
you in character this is yes so when
it's over the angel they play in that
show at one point we all go into the
like the past lives that the Angels had
when they were on earth and everyone
else had very glamorous past lives
except for me whose past life was that I
was a guy that lived and what just
watched her bog all day long and there
was I spent like two hours in makeup for
that and then we were on set for like
five minutes it was one shot of me just
eating mud that is you in a former life
and that reminds us Oh God
in previous appearances on the show
Daniel Radcliffe we've discovered this
thing at Daniel Radcliffe time traveller
okay so here just there suffers from
some of the hits we've seen so far
okay here's Daniel
I look like a lot of older women from
the past also looks like some men from
the past there you go can you spot him
in this can you see him yeah this is one
of my favorites this is him yeah it's
like a sterling Victorian lady anyway so
after that it's it's now got ridiculous
we get sent these all the time
next time Daniels aren't shown there
some of them are good like this this
does that is conceivably you or play him
in a film what is that is quite good yes
this in famous this is quite piss-poor
really that's just none of us
looks like bacteria that has this wider
purses but this one this one is this I
think it's maybe she's a lady gout show
or something I don't know what she is
but God it looks like you
[Applause]
[Music]
you